hello there and welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend i'm conan it's probably
obvious and uh i'm joined as always
that's not obvious
by now something's wrong uh joined by
sonam of secession hey sona hi oh okay
this isn't a morning show
a morning drive time show sorry it has
all the ingredients though yeah it sure
does we're doing some weather and
traffic in just a minute uh matt gourley
also joining us hey matt hey
you know what'd be great is if we did
use part of the budget to rent a
helicopter you know like the way someone
else would talk about traffic patterns
and what's happening and we have a
helicopter and it's flying around but
it's doing it's serving no function on
the podcast
what's it doing it's just i'm every now
and then i'm checking in with the
checking in with the colorblind needs a
friend chopper
you know and i'm just like hey conor
brown needs a friend chopper
you know we got uh aaron blair it's up
there hey aaron and uh aaron you can
come on mike hey everyone what's going
on and what we'll do is we'd put uh
you'd be in a chopper and you'd be
flying around los angeles and we'd just
be checking in with you every now and
then and it's a podcast so people listen
to it either now or six months from now
or they never listen to you're checking
in on the web traffic yeah how's the web
traffic blay metrics are high and the
ones and zeros are looking pretty good
but i think we got a hold up on the
packets uh coming from uh netscape
nice
all right
that was pretty good that was pretty
good he's not commenting at all on what
he's seeing in the helicopter no no the
helicopter
sona please i can't be more clear about
this the helicopter serves no function
and and i want when we play this i want
there to be helicopter noise ambient
helicopter noise around blay so you know
exactly what it's like
and i just uh hey
check in now with the uh conor bryant
needs a friend chopper again our man
blay up in the choppa that's our own
chopper that we bought uh that it used
to be uh chopper was formally used in
operation desert storm we purchased it
we purchased it for 1.6 million dollars
we painted the conan logo on the side
and aaron player is now high above los
angeles or by the 101 freeway how are
the downloads going the diamonds are
doing great
routers running pretty hot over here
cat5 cables a little bit of a mess you
can expect to slow down until mid
morning okay thank you very much for
that aaron blair we call him the blame
man up in the choppa
yeah
can i i have to go to the bathroom can i
come down
no
no we put a coffee can up there for a
reason
no no that is a coffee can that has a
specific purpose in mind
okay we'll be checking can i can i ask
him about what he's seeing like can i be
like hey how is that how's the weather
up there in the chopper no because that
actually
then that gives there to be
that gives there to be great job conan
i think it's chopper fumes that i'm high
on
that means that there's some purpose to
the chopper and it's important that the
chopper have no purpose so even if blai
said clear skies
um and people hear that when they listen
to this episode seven months after it
drops uh because they're on a long car
trip and their favorite podcast doesn't
have a new doesn't have a new drop uh
then um
i don't even want them to know what the
weather was like today it's got to be
useless information sona why can't you
get your head wrapped around i'm sorry
perfect concept hey can you fix it can
you fix it matt so that sona is in a
mini sub right now absolutely yeah some
solder
noises of course uh for this episode
sona is in a small this is a repurposed
1959 korean mini sub
that we purchased from the uh from the
uh korean government uh that's south
korean uh we try to get a north korean
one they are not i guess we're it's
illegal for us to trade with them uh
anyway uh sona how's it going you are
now says here you are 35 leagues under
the sea in the pacific ocean
uh off the island of muratu i believe i
just made up that island what's up sono
what do you see uh i just see a lot of
water and uh it's really it's really
cool and a little moist very good i
don't know i i'm not very good at uh at
being in
a sub well i don't know what to tell you
then clearly i don't know why you
volunteered to man the mini sub if you
now confess to us you're not very good
at being in a sub i did not volunteer
made me go down here bad improv to deny
what i just laid out um that could cause
damage to your sub
always yes and sona always yes and
that's the first thing you learn
when you join the navy yes and so let's
try that again okay sona you've clearly
been drinking a lot um in the mini sub
uh what kind of alcohol have you been
drinking yes and i uh had uh some you
know i had a couple martinis down here
and we yes just say tea many martinis
i had too many uh martinis awesomer
that's the old joke and it works even so
far
under the pacific ocean
surface of the pacific ocean uh anyway
back to our chopper now uh aaron um
tell us you're up in the chopper very
expensive choppa i love seeing choppa
aaron blaired up there in the chopper
right now tell us what what do you got
for us in the conan o'brien needs a
friend podcast choppa today seeing a lot
of pixelation in in the gifts jpegs and
the pngs but if you're going to be
downloading stuff make sure it's in raw
format because that's going to get you
the quality you need yeah that's the
kind of information that you need a
helicopter to provide
and sona of course
doing her best uh from uh now it says
doing her best it says you are a hundred
and twenty-two mono uh monocle nautical
monocle miles
i don't know what my
and i am in the in this submarine and it
is i am uh i'm exploring uh shipwrecks
sona you are taking on water very
quickly
for improv you don't say yes and in
every sentence it's going the spirit of
yes and but you don't say yes and that's
terrible improv in its own way oh okay
all right i am taking on water um i
don't i don't i wish i brought uh scuba
equipment instead of these martini
glasses
yes and that would have been a good idea
see doesn't quite work uh yes and let's
get this show started
yes and yeah i i'm gonna have quality
control experts come and uh
check the quality of this podcast open i
do i do fear and
what if blade wasn't a real chopper and
we were doing this conceptual bit about
how the chopper was unnecessary and then
uh blake crashed in that chopper that
would just be terrible
and i
no no he's not in a real chopper i can
make that joke but what i'm saying is i
would hate to have to tell his family
they'd be like why why was our son in a
chopper he didn't have to be in a
chopper
that's what was so funny about
it why did you put me in a submarine and
then actually asked me about what i was
seeing in the submarine i mean i don't
know why he can have a useless
helicopter but i i need to actually like
pay attention in my sons and my stomach
so what the [ __ ] is going on
[Laughter]
i invite anyone to edit this open
into something that makes some semblance
of sense no yes go ahead uh anyone out
there listening you feel free
to edit this together to either a make
more sense or b make less sense
and then
send it in
we'll let you know how you did